Film Courage: If a writer has three ideas,
how do they know which one to choose?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting Teacher and
Consultant: I think it depends on what they want
out of the writing project. I think there are a
few criteria you can look to and it's a really
personal decision. I also think you don't ever
have to throw an idea away if you have three that
you want to write, that means you're really just
choosing which one you're going to write next and
then you can always have the other two on deck. I
personally think that you should gauge the concept
and make sure that each idea you're weighing
is a strong enough idea to be a screenplay,
that's the first thing. But if all that's equal
I think you should look at what you want to get
out of the project. Is it helping you learn a new
skill in your writing toolkit? Is it helping you
advance your career in a particular way? Is it
filling out your portfolio of writing samples
so that is helpful to gauge what do I want this to
do for me so that no writing is wasted, it's not
wasted time but so that you're getting the most
out of of the project that you're going to write.
Then also if the ending I
think that's very helpful
because that sometimes if you start a
writing project without knowing the ending
that can be a longer, more frustrating process to
to outline that. But if you how this story ends,
the outlining of it, the figuring out how
the the plot progresses all the steps in the
plot and everything that's a little bit easier
because what destination you're headed towards,
so that's interesting. When you said that you've
actually outlined for people once you see their
finished script if you see someone who's hung
up on the ending, do you get them to that point
and then say okay now I mean I realize you're
not figuring out the ending for them but do you
outline up until that point and then maybe that
helps them through it? I'm making an outline from
a finished draft that someone's given me to read I
outline exactly what they have in the draft so if
their ending isn't working or if it isn't complete
and I have read scripts like that I will outline
exactly what they have and then we'll talk about
what's missing here is it is that the ending is
totally gone and you need to figure out what that
is or is it just that you've you've wrapped up
the plot but it's not it's really not complete or
resolving things as it needs to so I mean that's
just a normal a normal day in
in doing the script consults is
lot of times the ending needs work so we'll
just talk about like how can we strengthen that
sure but that sounds really helpful just again as
it's easier for someone to come in and organize
someone's space than if you have all these
personal mementos and like oh I can't get rid of
this I can't get rid of that oh my grandmother
gave me this but if the organizer comes in and
says how about we put this over here it yeah it
sounds like it's much easier yeah and I think that
I think that that's such a good analogy because
that is probably what it feels like as well if
you've written a draft and you're like here are
the scenes that I love and I want them to be in
there but something about it isn't working there
is that feeling of like I'm attached to these
things but I don't know how to organize them in a
way that they need to in order for it to like make
sense for everyone else as well sure yeah sure
and then you open the closet door and everything
falls yes and hence the screenplay might be really
jumbled and if we put it if we make sense to the
to the the viewer or the reader yeah yeah and
when when I go in there it's like I can outline
based on what they already have have and then we
can talk about okay so here's what we have so far
and then here's what the third act needs to do
like here's how it needs to resolve the plot and
wrap up character arc and all that stuff so what
are we missing and then we can fill in the holes
what is brain dump oh that's just something I'm
sure other people use it in different ways but
it's something that I think is a useful exercise
to do at the beginning of your your story breaking
process when you come up with an idea and you
haven't really done much to shape it yet I think
it's really useful to just sit down and write
down everything about that idea because you end
up capturing stuff that you maybe didn't realize
you knew about it or thought about it and then you
also end up capturing like what you love about
that idea when you're in that moment of still
being in love with it so that later on when you're
writing the script and you inevitably get to that
frustrating part where you get stuck or you don't
know what happens next and you are feeling like
why did I start writing this you can go back to
that brain dump and remember like what made me
fall in love with this idea to begin with or what
was it about this idea that in spite hired me how
did I want people to feel what were my hopes and
aspirations for this project before I went down
started down the long road of actually writing
it so yeah so if I have let's say a notebook
and it's my idea for this movie or this character
I'm just like this is my notebook where I'm going
to put the good, the bad and the ugly about this
character the story anything I can think of yeah
and I think it's probably different for every
project and for every writer like what comes
to mind I think it's useful to give yourself a
little bit of structure some parameters around the
brain dump but really it should be whatever about
your your project at that point in time so I just
think write down anything that where the idea
came from anything that inspires you about the
idea or how do you see this finished movie like
what other movies would it would would it be like
what's the soundtrack sound like are there
any songs that give you that feeling that you
want the movie to have talking about characters
for sure like who's the main character if that
what's that character like what relationships
does that character have who are the people in
his or her life anything that you come to the
table with when you're just getting inspired by
that idea like just starting to gather everything
that about it that you're going to start shaping
into the story eventually like because at the
beginning it's like you have a jumble of ideas
I think you have oh this would be a great scene
or oh I think it ends like this maybe with this
final shot I don't know how we get there
but it's them riding off into the sunset or
I I don't know who this character is but I think
that there's a guy who had this background or has
this affectation and I wonder how he got to be
that way and so it's just a it's just a way for
you to start to gather like all of those little
tidbits that you think might belong to this story
put them all in one place so that you don't have
that that feeling of like that nervous feeling of
like I'm gonna forget this idea and I don't know
where it goes yet and so you're all stressed out
about trying to work it into the story you can put
it all in one place and just hold it there so that
as you're working through that development process
you can always go back to it and reference it come
up with those ideas that you had at one time that
maybe you'd forgotten about so so let's suppose I
was Eric Roth and I was thought of this idea for
this Forrest Gump character or based on a book
whatever and and I thought okay here's my here's
my notebook with forest in it and so southern town
loving mom definitely health problems with with
his legs different things and then meets Jenny
meets Bubba all these different things meets
Captain Dan you know different fights different
things and his goal of being this just
this theme through his life of of being in
like these interesting places at the time and
helping people he's almost like a helper yeah
and so I'm just like getting it out this is
Forest this is there wasn't really anything
bad about him but these are some of the things
that that make up this Forest character yeah and
hopefully if you're working on that project or
you're inspired enough to sit down and start to
gather your thoughts hopefully there's something
about who that character is that you really like
or that interests you at least and so so those
are the things that I think you should focus
on because those are going to be the things that
help you later on in the story like having those
touchstones of like oh yeah I remember I really
wanted this character to have this particular
feeling or to maybe have this particular
arc to learn this lesson across this story
so yeah I don't even know if you I guess if that
much about your story it's great and write it
all down but you don't even have to try to
shape it in the brain dump process I think
I wouldn't put pressure on yourself to try to
come up with like oh this is first act stuff
and this is where the story goes from there it's
just whatever whatever sparks your interest when
you think about that particular idea and I
always like the the prompts or questions you
ask yourself about like what do how do I see
this in its finished form even if it's not
specifics but it's like how do I want people to
feel when they see it or what does the soundtrack
sound like is a good one because it's like what
feelings does it give you when you hear the music
or what music makes you think of this idea or
make you feel the way this idea makes you feel
and then I also one other thing that I think is
really helpful to do in the brain dump process is
think about what the story means to you because
that helps you start to narrow in on the theme
of the story which I think is one of those things
that like it really intimidates a lot of writers
it feels like oh I have to come up with some
big profound statement but really you're just
trying to come up with like the the mean what
does it mean to you like what's the takeaway
message or big idea that this story imparts and
that can be really daunting and intimidating so
if you do it in the brain dump process where
you're just free-flowing and brainstorming
it gives you a pressure free and environment
to think about like what does the story mean
like what lesson would this character learn or
what lesson could this experience teach someone
and what's the story about for me like what
does it what does it mean to me inside that
I that I want to get at or explore in the story
okay so I wouldn't necessarily know maybe all of
these things when I mentioned Lieutenant Dan
and these things I would just know that it's
a character maybe the odds were stacked against
him but he didn't really have a mean streak in
him he didn't need to get revenge on people yeah
or maybe what have been done to him or or he was
still just a kind-hearted guy yeah and I think
maybe if you were developing that story idea
in the brain dump process you might not know the
specifics about those other characters but you
might say okay I have this main character that I'm
really interested in I think his name's Forrest
Gump and he's this type of guy he's a he's such
a kind person he doesn't have a mean bone in his
body and the kinds of people that he could run
into that would create conflict and help him
move through the story might be someone who he's
in love with who doesn't reciprocate and so he has
to contend with that set of emotions maybe he has
a mentor character that he meets in the unlikely
place of in the in the military it's been a long
time since I saw that so I don't remember if Dan
is the mentor but maybe he meets somebody who's
very gruff and the opposite of him personality
wise maybe he meets Bubba who in some ways is
similar like innocent and sees the world in a
particular way and so by pairing up with that
person these are the kinds of things that he
might experience or lessons that he might learn
or situations he might find himself in you know.